Hey Youtubers it's Charlie so you may have
heard Marvel and Fox are teaming up for two
new TV shows based on X-Men properties the
first one is going to be a 60s hellfire club
like set back in the 60s the others going
to be sure about Legion that the son of Prof.
X is a lot of questions about who owns the
rights to what because technically Fox owns
X-Men rights Marvel has almost everything
else not including Spiderman in a pending
Sony sharing agreement but here's the deal
Fox only owns the rights to do X-Men movies
they don't have the TV rights Marvel still
owns those so because Fox has a huge X-Men
franchise they've course want to capitalize
that in there big TV business so they had
to come to terms just like Marvel came to
terms with Sony over Spiderman so Marvel and
Fox will be coproducing these two new TV series
we know little bit more about what's going
on with the Legion TV show it's going to air
on FX that the same channel because American
horror story the strain sons of anarchy has
a bunch of good shows will be basic cables
they can make it as crazy as they want to
do a lot more rules about the major broadcast
networks alike shows that are on NBC Fox give
the really big channels they can't be quite
as graphic most of the fun of the Legion character
is that he has crazy superpowers is a bunch
of different superpowers but he has multiple
personality disorder with each personality
controlling a different superpower so you
know about the Lucifer TV show that Fox is
doing is it's kind like that idea you have
a character it's not really a good person
but is going to be a lot of fun to watch the
way they talk about Marvel and Fox working
together it sounds like the Legion show is
going to be produced at Marvel with a lot
of input from the Fox people for the most
part the physical production itself will happen
with Marvel resources is sidestepping to the
hellfire club that's a bit more of a known
property because they're primarily going to
flow from the energy of X-Men first class
although I don't think they're going to use
a lot of those actors the pry recast a lot
of people but they have access to all the
big ones will be able to do Sebastian Shaw
Emma Frost I'm kinda hoping they don't bring
January Jones back she was at the least interesting
part of that movie but it unlike the Legion
show is going to be more of like a Fox production
with input from Marvel creatively Brian singers
attached executive produce he's done a couple
big TV shows in the past I think that the
biggest one recently was house in the it only
makes sense that he is kind like the Shepherd
of the X-Men franchise that Fox right now
so naturally he's going to get involved in
their biggest TV series most of my interaction
with X-Men on Fox TV is been through the animated
series like the classic 90 series one of my
favorite cartoons of all time you watch it
now it's a little bit slow but the stories
mostly hold up their really good the way think
about the hellfire club in the X-Men universe
is the way most people think about the in
humans in the marvel universe technically
their powerful but they've always kinda been
this weird little offshoot group like most
people when they think about X-Men team ups
they think about the X-Men themselves Prof.
Xavier's X-Men and then they think of the
brotherhood of mutants or even like the more
locks the hellfire club was always unique
because it can invoke a lot of blood.
Drama you have is very anachronistic seeming
characters they seem out of place no matter
when their living even in the 60s Sebastian
Shaw have been living for a long time but
your flashback to him being an off the is
from a visual perspective expected to look
similar to the look of the 60s in the X-Men
movies if you want to read about the hellfire
club in the comics something relatively recent
that actually use them in up in an interesting
way is X-Men legacies starting with the 2012
run most people say like older hellfire club
at the classic stuff kinda sucks so you can
like skip a lot of that stuff just start with
the 2012 legacy run the first and actually
showed up was X-Men 129 by Chris Claremont
and John Byrne they they were the ones that
created the hellfire club and the most notable
people that are been part of the club are
Sebastian Shaw course Emma Frost the White
Queen Harry Leyland Donald Pierce Tessa Celine
was kind like the opposite of Emma Frost is
kind of an even more evil version of Emma
Frost then there's magneto has been a part
of it briefly storm nobody Shaw Trevor Fitzroy
Madeleine Pryor was actually pretty cool character
Seder nine Phoenix and sunspot so that she
had a pretty big membership I'm not expecting
them to have all those characters some of
the X-Men people will be movies only the same
thing with DC TV shows in the films Fox just
like DC probably feels like he can earn more
money off of certain characters if there only
in the films than if there also on TV shows
but if you like sometimes having characters
on TV shows devalues the maybe that is my
opinion as either trying to keep certain people
from getting overexpose that they don't want
Jean Grey becoming the Phoenix on TV if she's
gonna be doing it unlike a giant widescreen
movie projector that she haven't made any
official comments about who they're going
to cast for the show which characters the
gonna use just expect to see the core hellfire
club people just expect them to have fun with
some of those tropes is just the way small
though use the idea of checkmate in different
chess pieces for different people in the organization
or exposure to the hellfire club in the movies
is relatively limited and they didn't get
really into the minutiae of actual club is
religious Sebastian Sean acting his plans
for world domination he didn't see a lot of
like what was going on between people inside
the club hellfire club showed up in uncanny
X-Men but Legion showed up in new mutants
which also heavily featured X force and Deadpool
love a lot of other things were going to be
seeing from Fox there is still next force
movie floating out there somewhere they just
they they won't make it till after they're
done with Deadpool so let me know in the comments
what you guys think about the idea of X-Men
live-action TV shows with hellfire club characters
everybody has like their favorite X-Men characters
most Nintendo the film only the devil has
like a slightly better shot of jumping to
a TV shows depending on how much money his
movie makes they might not be quite as protective
of him in the film universe Fox X-Men going
to be a lot of fun that they're not too afraid
to do edgier TV show so think of it as being
like slightly edgier than what's going on
in the CW right now like the flash and arrow
they didn't announce a premier date but they
can actually turn pilots over pretty quickly
when deals have been made use of the problem
is is just like making that arrangement with
the other studio if you need the rights to
something what they might do is shoot a pilot
sometime next year for like a 2017 air date
if the shows get picked up now they haven't
been picked up efficiently to heaven like
green lit the entire run they just started
development on pilots but if it turns into
a think I will totally do videos for it every
week is or any X-Men videos the guys want
me to do her or Deadpool videos just let me
know in the comments on due for a new Deadpool
videos in the movie is actually coming out
in February just in case you guys haven't
seen in a while you can click here for my
last Deadpool video and you can click here
for my arrow episode two video from last night
they just introduced anarchy on the show thank
you so much for watching everybody high five
to see guys tonight